[Music]
it's time for et's social study a quick
look at what the stars are posting
online Tara Reid penned an emotional
message about her late father on
Instagram writing quote he was my heart
my soul and my entire world I love you
and we'll miss you so much daddy
switching gears at J Lo's a vocal coach
Stevie Mackey shared this clip of the
superstar sneaking a smooch from rumor
new man Drake at a party Thursday night
things definitely seemed to be heating
up for the possible couple I myself
incredibly blessed and Miley Cyrus and
Liam Hemsworth seemed to be stronger
than ever
fate visited a San Diego Children's
Hospital together this week meanwhile
Kelly Ripa is enjoying a getaway in the
mountains and we gotta say her 19 year
old son Michael is looking at just like
his dad at Mark Consuelos I hope so
Madonna is also spending her winter
break on the slopes she shared this
sweet snap with family and friends and
posted a pretty impressive video of her
11 year old son of David catching major
air then there's Ryan Seacrest who
apparently got trapped in an elevator on
his way to work on New Year's rockin Eve
ringing an alarm
sure yeah oh don't worry they got out
you
[Music]